there is a
horrifying story that just came out of
georgia
the story is that two homosexual men
have been charged with using their
adopted children to record child
pornography these guys are william and
zachary zulock
they have the same name i assume they're
not brothers so i don't know what one of
the other guy one guy took the other
guy's name i guess
they adopted two kids and then they used
the kids to make child pornography
not the first time we've heard this
story
this story even though gay marriage has
not existed as a concept for more than
seven years really and not at the
national level even though gay adoption
is
still illegal in a whole lot of places
and it's a very novel concept we keep
hearing these stories it's kind of weird
there's another story they tell you
these stories they don't happen it's one
in a bazillion well i don't know there's
another story came around from
queensland
uh this story
uh oh gosh this is awful the headline
is in yahoo news
he was a child star but for all the
wrong reasons he made his debut at just
22 months old not for a toy store
advertisement or even a family-friendly
pg film this was for hardcore global
pornographic syndication he was filmed
being sexually abused by his adoptive
parents quote unquote and at least eight
other pedophiles in australia france
germany and the united states
uh his horrific introduction to the
insidious world of pedophilia dated back
to 2005 when his russian mother sold him
for eight thousand dollars to a member
of boy lovers a sophisticated global
network of men whose sexual preference
for boys aged between six and uh eight
years old
uh the boy was adopted quote unquote by
american mark j newton who lived in
brisbane and his australian boyfriend
peter trong
now what's really crazy about this story
is that there had previously been a puff
piece about this couple a puff piece
about how wonderful it was that they
adopted this boy because back this is
2013 now the idea of gay adoption was
really pretty much unthinkable at that
point and so there was this big puff
piece being pushed by the liberal media
to say look they've overcome so many
obstacles legal and social to finally
have their fulfillment to
to adopt their child and form this
family despite the constraints of nature
and society that that article is even
referenced in this
in this
article on their crimes
look how it turned out look how it
turned out didn't turn out
great the conclusion from this and i
know a lot of squishes aren't going to
want to say it
homosexual adoption is a terrible idea
it's a terrible idea and it's i think
just simply unsupportable you can't
it's it's just unacceptable for not
because
every kid who's adopted by homosexuals
is going to be abused i don't think
that's the case we are seeing a lot of
stories like this it's pretty weird but
that's that's that's not even the base
reason why the base reason why is that
men and women are different
and little i got a little baby at home
right now let me tell you something
little baby reacts very differently to
mama than he does to daddy even my older
son
who's a little bit older than the
newborn reacts very differently to mommy
than he does to daddy
wants different things from mommy
wants because men and women are
different if you believe that men and
women are different i don't see how you
can support homosexual adoption
because men and women have different
things to offer
and when we're talking about adoption
especially when we're talking about
conception especially when we're talking
about an issue like surrogacy or all
these other issues that keep coming up
all we ever talk about now are the
rights of the right of these men
to have a child these men don't have a
right to have a child they can't have a
child together
there's a very
natural scientific basis for why they
can't have a child together and now
they're trying to circumvent that nature
through this radical social engineering
and things don't turn out very well
the only people who we ever talk about
as having rights in these cases are the
are the couples and the couples and
their deep desire to have a child you
don't have a right to have a child
i know it can be hard for people who
especially people who struggle with
infertility or i'm sure it's very hard
for homosexuals too who have a natural
desire to have a child that's a natural
thing to want
but you don't have a right to a child
sweet little elise and i even dealt with
what what seemed like infertility for
quite some time we didn't get our first
kid right away i i can tell you at least
from a couple years experience i know i
know how intense that pain can be but
you do not have a right to a child you
don't
the only person who can be said to have
any rights when we're talking about
procreation when we're talking about
adoption or anything like that the only
person who can be said to have any
rights is the child
a child has a right to his natural
mother and father conceived in the act
of in the conjugal act between his
parents in a marriage
marriage which is the lifelong bond
between a man and a woman for the sake
of the generation and education of
children that's what it's for
and when you start
tinkering with that things go really
really awry
the the inability of these two men to
have a child
is a kind of
it's a i'm sure it was a pain i mean
these these guys are just absolute
criminals who are going to rot but for
for other people
it is a pain
pain is not always a bad thing pain is
not an evil thing suffering is not
exactly an evil thing it's kind of just
a fact of life what
is determines good or evil is how you
react to pain how you react to suffering
sometimes pain can be even a good thing
because it tells you that you should
maybe alter your behavior when you put
your hand on the hot stove burner and it
hurts that pain tells you okay i gotta
take my hand away
they're all sorts when you're in a rut
in your life
you feel a kind of pain that tells you
you've got to change certain things all
sorts of personal behaviors when you
feel a kind of pain you're drinking too
much whatever you've got to change that
behavior unfortunately in our
therapeutic culture and in our culture
that establishes the domination of
technology to break off all natural
constraints
all we tend to do is numb the pain
so you're you're in a rut in your life
well just take a bunch of depression
drugs
and then that's not solving the problem
that's not encouraging
behavior that's more conducive to human
flourishing
it's just kind of numbing the pain a
little bit you don't change a damn thing
that is a much it goes even beyond sex
it goes even beyond questions of
adoption it goes down to a fundamental
issue of how we as human beings
react to one another and to our society
and to technology
we seem to be entering into a brave new
world you know there are two very famous
dystopian novels about written in the
20th century about the future 1984 by
george orwell
and brave new world by aldous huxley
in 1984 says that the tyrannical
government's just going to beat you with
a stick all the time
brave new world says the tyrannical
government is going to apply you with
drugs and sex and promiscuity and all
sorts of pleasures both are going to
make you into slaves we're getting a
little bit of both in our society today
it's clearly clearly accelerating
on the personal front on the cultural
front on the destruction of the family
and ultimately on the political front
too the powers that be are sicking
federal law enforcement on their
political opponents things happen slow
and gradually then they can happen
really really fast we might be in the
fast stage right now go to epicwell.com
use code knowles the left's persistent
and loud attack on the truth is aimed
directly at your children you see in the
public school system you see it in the
mainstream kids entertainment you see it
on social media platforms seemingly all
of our nation's cultural institutions
have been infiltrated by the left's
not-so-secret agenda as they say to
indoctrinate your kids with
anti-religious anti-american ideologies
they prey on the vulnerability and
malleability of your kids brains and
they seek to warp your kids
understanding of themselves and their
environment there are a lot of ways you
can protect your kids from these not so
secret agendas you can homeschool you
get them involved in your church
but one of the easiest and simplest ways
to protect your kids is to take five
minutes tonight and write a will with
epic will a will gives you the power to
say who will raise your kids should
something god forbid happen to you and
your spouse it can in certain cases be
the only legal defense standing between
your kids and the persistent power grabs
from the left epic will is an online
will platform costs less than your next
trip to target they can set you up with
a will in as little as five minutes
starts at just 119
plus you can save 10 when you go to epic
will.com use code knowles take five
minutes tonight write a will ensuring
that your kids will be raised the way
that you would intend in the event that
something happens to you go to
epicwhell.com use code knowles today
i'm so glad you like that clip now hold
up stop you got to ring that bell we've
hit 1 million subscribers that's great
thrilled about that we need to hit one
billion okay we have to we have to we
have no other choice so ring that bell
subscribe get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you